the star power here tonight is
unbelievable you got that right vanessa
and while the stranger thinks cass deals
with a very scary monster this season
jamie campbell bower tells us about the
song that would help him out if i'm
being cheeky and and and fun it would be
miley cyrus party in the usa
[Music]
it's a party in la kicking off the mtv
movie and tv awards because what's a
party without double g snoop dogg
make some noise for our dj tonight dj
snoopadelic
i was so busy doing snoop dogg
nobody does it better snoop and what's
an award show without j-lo
you are the reason that i am here
taking home the iconic popcorn trophy
for the generation where j.lo makes it
clear
she's on her way home to her man and
then and everybody at home
wait for me to have dinner i'll be home
by 7.
how would i describe this chapter for
life
there you go
and the golden popcorn goes to
olivia rodrigo
yes the queen of sad songs nab's best
music documentary because you know we're
still obsessed with driver's license
please welcome chris evans
chris evans is in the building and the
best movie winner of the night hit it
chris
spider-man no way home
well tom and zendaya take home one
golden popcorn they had some um
unexpected competition for best gifts i
love anytime someone kisses someone on
the show and you have to like um when
they do the kiss awards and they have
the big they have the big spiderman kiss
ah sorry megan no spidey kiss this time
plot twist a snake won the kissing crown
and to keep the kissing tradition alive
here's one more snake smooch a sentence
you know what i never thought i'd say
[Applause]